every day it was worse and worse they
are two sisters sharing one story about
leaving home we couldn't stay there
this is what they left behind mariupol
basically being reduced to rubble and
cut off without phones or internet twin
sisters anastasia and hannah richkina
didn't understand what was going on they
thought that maybe if no one is safe
comes to save us maybe the world just
doesn't know about the situation
that's how we saw it
now on the day of the invasion the
sisters say at first they didn't realize
it was happening their city was fought
over in 2014 when russia-backed rebels
took over parts of the donbass region in
the eight years since it was close
enough to the front lines they could
sometimes hear fighting off in the
distance
the explosions when the invasion started
were closer i said mom putin attacked a
maripo now and then we realized that
it's a real war it's not what we're used
to in mariupol
what came next was weeks of scrounging
and hunger in the first days they
rationed the little they had then they
scavenged searching friends homes and
apartments people who'd left looking for
anything we were checking
every shelf if they have something and i
was happy oh my god i found the candle
oh my god i found the
rice or i found something else
the challenge after that was what to do
with what they found without gas or
electricity everything had to be cooked
over a fire out in the open
exposed when you need to go outside to
cook food and then there is shelling and
you need to hide there is a constantly
sound of the airplane but you need to go
outside anyways because you cannot
survive without food
the sisters were able to escape they're
still in ukraine but at least safer
their ride out of marijuana was a
stranger who agreed to take their group
just somewhere
i don't know where we where we going i
don't know how
how much time it will take but i was
happy that i'm i'm in a car i'm i'm all
we are all is with our our family and
that's all i wanted
now there is one thing the sisters feel
guilty about locking the door to their
apartment there isn't much but there is
some food left food they say their
neighbors likely need
desperately
mike armstrong global news krakow poland